salud en directo América de France 24
hoy viernes nos acompaña en el estudio
más Romero sala mar para hablar de un
tema importante porque hoy es el Día de
la eliminación de la violencia contra
las mujeres y las niñas una carga que
también afecta a su salud si Raúl 25 de
noviembre se conmemora esta fecha y las
estimaciones de la Organización Mundial
de la Salud son que una de cada tres
mujeres han sufrido a lo largo de su
vida violencia física o sexual además
también importante recordar que la mayor
parte la mayor parte de los casos los
agresores son las parejas o personas
conocidas dentro del vínculo de Los
vínculos cercanos de las mujeres
víctimas no las consecuencias de estas
violencias son diversas hablamos
particularmente de la salud por supuesto
haya lesiones a raíces de los actos
violentos también problemas de salud
sexual por ejemplo abortos espontáneos
embarazos no deseados o más prevalencia
de enfermedades de transmisión sexual en
estos casos por supuesto también de
Salud Mental no las consecuencias que
pueden haber alrededor de las
depresiones de trastornos de ansiedad
también insomnio trastornos alimentarios
la lista es muy largas solo algunas y
también en general y algo muy concreto
son que normalmente Estas mujeres que
sufren nos sufrimos violencias en
nuestro día a día eso se traslada
también en Dolores dolores de cabeza
dolores de espalda dolores gastos
intestinales no como esa forma en la que
se manifiestan en nuestro cuerpo Exacto
como este tipo de tensiones Pues también
son muy importantes y los tenemos que
recordar Y lamentablemente también mar
Pues los agresores en muchas ocasiones
Son liberados son no no son Opuestos
tras las rejas o son puestos hasta las
rejas pues lo liberan Más allá de las
consecuencias de la violencia desde la
ciencia y la salud cómo se sienten estas
diferencias de género más pues en
general el estudio de la medicina
siempre ha tenido una visión
profundamente masculina no Y eso ha
conllevado que haya un desconocimiento
alrededor de los cuerpos de las mujeres
que se traduce también en consecuencias
sobre su propia salud por ejemplo vamos
hablar de los ataques al corazón no un
problema que normalmente se relaciona
mucho con la salud de los hombres y que
se relaciona también con ese dolor
intenso en el pecho y en el brazo que
eso significa que tienes un ataque en el
corazón si bien es cierto que como vemos
aquí esa presión en el pecho también la
comparten las mujeres en su
sintomatología No necesariamente es el
síntoma más perceptible para las mujeres
cuando tienen este tipo de problema hay
otros otros síntomas que presentan no y
los Tenemos aquí por ejemplo pueden ser
molestias en otras partes del cuerpo
como el cuello el abdomen la mandíbula
también náuseas o vómitos una cansancio
inusual aturdimiento mareo sudoración o
incluso también acidez estomacal
Entonces es muy importante que tengamos
en cuenta esto y que intentemos poco a
poco romper esta brecha de esta mirada
tan masculina sobre el cuerpo de las
mujeres y sobre la ciencia que hace que
eso tengan consecuencias sobre la salud
otro ejemplo también mar de violencia
contra las mujeres en la salud es la
violencia obstétrica No que muy poco
también se habla de ella sí tres
ejemplos no este primero ahora vamos por
el segundo y el tercero de formas en que
estas violencias se manifiesta Sí en el
campo de la salud y esta violencia
obstétrica se define por ejemplo como el
desconocimiento de las necesidades
emocionales o físicas de la madre o del
bebé tanto durante el embarazo como
durante el parto como durante el
puerperíodo inmediato que es
precisamente esos momentos después del
parto no además también de minar la
autonomía o la capacidad de decisión de
las mujeres o de las personas que están
gestando sobre su sexualidad sobre su
cuerpo sobre como decíamos esas
decisiones que quieren tomar las cifras
difieren muchos muy difícil ponerle
números a este tipo de cosas porque
depende de la percepción de las
pacientes no Entonces es difícil que
haya una una medición una parámetro
claro para medir este tipo de violencias
Aunque eso no deja de ser importante
porque precisamente esas percepciones de
las mujeres suelen estar muy
subestimadas en la salud y en la
medicina y de nuevo esta mirada
masculina pasa por no poner la mujer en
el centro no trajimos un ejemplo de un
estudio de la organización Panamericana
de la salud que hizo en Chile que
reportaba que más del 79% de mujeres
encuestadas habían reportado sufrir
algún tipo de violencia obstétrica
durante el parto durante su experiencia
del embarazo y daba algunos indicadores
estadísticos que son estos que vemos
aquí como de Cuántas mujeres habían
dicho haber sufrido esto vemos que la
que más prevalencia tiene fue que fueron
obligadas a quedarse por ejemplo en la
cama tumbadas sin opción de Buscar otras
formas de moverse según sin escuchar lo
que el mismo cuerpo les pidiera no pero
también procedimientos médicos sin
consentimiento la dificultad de
preguntar o manifestar miedos o
inquietudes y críticas y comentarios
sobre el cuerpo o sobre la experiencia
también Hablamos mar del caso de las
mujeres trans que pasa con estas mujeres
no si nunca nunca es suficiente recordar
que la esperanza de vida de las mujeres
trans en América Latina es de 45 años
eso se debe a muchas causas una de ellas
es precisamente ese rechazo que hay o
ese empeoramiento de la salud y ese
rechazo que hay las personas trans y las
mujeres transcudir a consultas médicas
porque no suelen ser espacios seguros
para ellas no estos este gráfico recoge
datos de 2020 en Estados Unidos y recoge
unos tipos de discriminación para
personas trans o personas trans
racializadas vemos que por ejemplo usar
un nombre equivocado erróneo también
usar el género erróneo con el que se
identifica la persona le sucedió entre
el 25% de las personas trans que
acudieron a la consulta también a varios
ejemplos alrededor del 25% una de cada
cuatro personas que acuden a consultas
indican haber recibido pues lenguaje
abusivo o tratamiento Hasta físico
abusivo entonces este tipo de cosas hace
que se alejen las personas trans de las
consultas médicas a las mujeres
particularmente se desconozcan sus
cuerpos se desconozcan sus necesidades y
eso también conlleve pues una pérdida de
salud de estas personas mar digamos
tenemos tiempo para seguir conversando
sobre este tema además es que usted lo
sigue bastante de cerca por supuesto
pero también este año vimos un hito pues
importante también lamentable para un
sector de la sociedad en Estados Unidos
fue esta derogación de El fallo
histórico Robert versus wade que
permitía no de manera Federal a las
mujeres a decidir sobre sí interrumpir
su embarazo o no sin ningún tipo de
digamos de señalamiento por parte de los
médicos también como como esto se puede
ver como un retroceso para salir para la
salud reproductiva de las mujeres de las
personas gestantes mar y alrededor del
tema del aborto yo creo que además se
pone siempre en la arena política como
un debate que es meramente ideológico o
meramente moral cuando en realidad
también es un debate como bien dices
sobre la salud de las mujeres sobre el
derecho a la salud de las mujeres hay
muchísimos estudios muchísimas cifras
que que las mujeres siguen abortando así
el aborto se ha permitido o no y que lo
único que cambia al final es si lo hacen
en condiciones de seguridad o en
condiciones de inseguridad por ejemplo
cuando hablamos de condiciones de
inseguridad es decir que no haya un buen
seguimiento médico la posibilidad de que
haya infecciones durante el
procedimiento que tengan problemas de
salud después del aborto y no puedan
acudir a un médico por miedo a ser
denunciadas por estar infringiendo una
ley no entonces todas estas cosas
influyen muy directamente en la salud de
las mujeres en el momento de decidir qué
hacer y también además les restan como
decíamos muchísima agencia a la hora de
decidir sobre el propio cuerpo sobre qué
quieren aunque no quieren hacer sobre su
propia salud no Entonces por supuesto es
un retroceso al final sobre todo en
términos de eso de salud pública de
salud para las mujeres porque como bien
usted él lo decía mar pues Esto va a
seguir pasando lo avale el gobierno o no
lo vale el gobierno de turno en
cualquier país del mundo mar Muchísimas
gracias a como siempre por toda la
información para hablar esos temas de
salud feliz fin de semana y el lunes por
supuesto más nos vemos el lunes